I don't
[Music]
there wasn't any evidence silver lining
now I know their religions real they
have a hell and it does not look good do
you think he could do it the answer is
no if God exists it's me yes Rick
I agree Rick well you were flapping your
Paris hey everybody knew Rick and Morty
so after episode eight I got a lot of
questions about hey wait a minute does
this mean that there is a God in one of
the Rick and Morty universes or multiple
universes because during episode six the
toxic version of Rick declares himself
to be God if there is a God then it's
got to be me the pastor the church even
declares that they invented God for
money when they become toxic so I think
there are a couple clues pointing to
what's going on with these higher and
lower planes of existence going back to
season two but there is a new round of
that merch giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video I'll announce a
new winner at the end of this so you go
all the way back to season two and get
schwifty the chrome ulong scum they
literally are the most powerful beings
that we've ever met so powerful that
they can create galactic reality shows
just forcing lower beings to do their
bidding you really don't learn that much
more about them other than the left-turn
that they were going to kill everybody
anyway until ice tea came and used his
powers and went back to alpha beat reom
some of the more weak willed people band
together and create a religion called
head ism because they can literally
control the weather principal vagina the
name's réal possibly Scandinavian I'm
just gonna come out and make this [ __ ]
the old gods are dead all previous
existing religions all hail the one true
God the giant head in the sky Bob Bob I
get it but unless this can beat that
what have you done for me lately so if
you won't excuse me I'm going out onto
the sidewalk I'm dropping to my knees
and pledging my eternal soul to the
thing that literally controls the
[ __ ] weather my way as funny as that
was it was just an example of how
quickly some of these people will throw
away their previously deeply held
beliefs in the face of utter
annihilation
it seems a lot more likely based on
Rick's comments about how these people's
religion seems to be real that there are
just really powerful beings that people
have worshipped as gods we're there to
actually be something that would
approach what you would consider a God
Rick would probably have a scientific
explanation for it like during pickle
Rick where he denounces therapy I'm a
scientist I create and destroy I didn't
you want to come here because I don't
respect therapy because I'm a scientist
because I invent transform create and
destroy for a living and when I don't
like something about the world I change
it and I don't think going to a rented
office in a strip mall to listen to some
agent of averageness explain which words
mean which feelings has ever helped
anyone do anything it's like the Thor
Doctor Strange thing over in the Marvel
Universe Thor says that magic is just
science that you haven't explained yet
and then when we got to Doctor Strange
people are like wait a minute but there
is magic but even then the thing is is
they explained that Doctor Strange and
Loki's magic in the Marvel Universe is
just them pulling power from other
dimensions is the same way Marvel's
tesseract work it's sort of like this
zero-point energy module of infinite
energy from another dimension some
benevolent and life-giving
no no no a portal to the blender
dimension that's the oldest trick in the
book I'm a Rick I'm more Rick than any
of you so based on all Rick and Morty's
evidence it just seems like there are
different levels of beings and as you
get more powerful people begin to
worship them as deities but the even
more interesting idea is that the more
powerful the beings get the less they
care about the beings beneath them think
about Rick the mini verse in the
Microverse like he didn't even care
about the Microverse he cared a little
bit about the mini verse because they
were creating power for his ship like
they're essentially his battery but when
he learned about the even lesser beings
in the micro universe within the mini
verse he could just give a [ __ ] that
just sounds like slavery with extra
Depp's what wait a minute did you create
my universe is my universe a mini verse
Microverse teeny verse you bastard much
obliged this is healthy trust me so when
Rick says there is no God I'm God that's
really just his narcissism talking that
was one of the things he removed from
himself his narcissism his loneliness
rudeness and attachment to Morty we're
all considered toxic so you have to
assume that he's not being literal when
he says there is no God if there is one
he would be me so let me know in the
comments what do you think the closest
thing to God is in the Rick and Morty
multiverse I would say Rick but the
thing is is that the chromia ons would
have destroyed Rick had it not been for
iced tea so the minute that another more
powerful being comes along you
immediately get knocked off that
pedestal hold on a second let's be
rational about this
no I'm just saying we don't know there's
a cause-effect relationship
[Music]
what the hell happened mr. president
you're gonna want to see this
I think Planet Earth has just been
transported the head has left and sent
its children holy crap oh dear giant
head we apologize for that discussion it
will never happen again but without
completely answering the question I
think that Dan Harmon and the other
writers in real life are a little more
cynical on the topic so I'm not
expecting them to ever officially answer
that question so it just open-ended like
there could just be more powerful beings
that we haven't met yet which we
probably will but there'll be some new
Rick and Morty episode 9 tomorrow I'm
also going to post a non-spoilery Star
Trek discovery episode 1 review later
tonight because I had a chance to see
the episode it'll say congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Carlos Zavala
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you win one of those new
art books there'll be a new round when I
post that new Rick and Morty you can
click here for brand new episode 9 and
you can click here for all my other Rick
and Morty
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]